joining me now Jim Jordan ranking member
of the House Oversight Committee
congressman I got to tell you I've been
around here longer than you have for a
long time in this city I've seen a lot
this was one of the most disgusting
displace and in both instances I want to
get your reaction well this is this is
beyond beyond you have it you had it
exactly right when your entire focus is
on attacking and stopping the president
you can't do what's best for the country
yet in spite of that this is the amazing
thing and you had this in your in your
angle in spite of that the president's
record in two and a half years of
achieving good things for the country is
unbelievable I mean we you you I always
go down the list regulations reduce
taxes conduct judgment we got an amazing
rate Gorsuch and Cavanaugh in the court
and a lot of other judges confirm we're
out of the Iran deal the embassies in
Jerusalem hostages home from North Korea
NAFTA the new nap in the USMC a ready to
go but congressman they not only won't
work with Trump there their entire modus
operandi right now is to slash at him up
to 2020 so we're gonna get into this
crisis at the border which has now
reached epic proportions but I want to
play a street just for just from
chuckles MSNBC's Chuck Todd says that
the Republican Party tonight is in
danger because they only have really
accomplished one thing let's watch
everybody else is going along with us
like do you be careful catch in this car
it seems like you're playing with
matches near a gas you Republicans at
some point do they want to sit here and
have their only accomplishment be
protecting Trump well like you said we
got Gorsuch and cabin all on the court
we're out of the Iran deal the embassies
in Jerusalem hostages to come home from
North Korea the economy is growing at
three point two percent Louis
unemployment in 50 years I think that's
a pretty good that's a pretty good thing
to protect that agenda regulations
reduce I think it's a pretty good record
to run on I think the bigger question is
what you raise the only thing the
Democrats are gonna have to run on is
attacking the president who's
responsible for all those good things
and they are so focused on attacking
they actually have these secret
memorandums of understanding where the
various key chairmen the Oversight
Committee then the Judiciary Committee
the financial services the ways that
means and and of course
the Intel committee with chairmanship
they have these memory a basic contract
saying here's how we're gonna coordinate
our attacks on the president cuz our
singular focus is going after the guy
who has helped they couldn't have years
of all the great things that have
happened was it in the country could the
president have gone forward with the
meeting and be in Ben I'm reading some
of the Republican criticism you know
it's all bush people sorry but gone
through with a meeting and worked out
some deal with them and shown that he's
the bigger person would that have been
smarter that's that's the president's
call I will tell you what though you
I think you put any of any American any
human being in that situation where they
they're criticizing a couple hours
before come into the meeting where they
got this memorandums of understanding
coordinated attack on you every angle
you can think of asking for eight years
of your business records eight years of
your of your banking records asking for
your tax records I mean that's you
forgot dental that's what we have so the
Ways and Means Committee I want his tax
records tax return the Oversight
Committee give me eight years of his
business they say it's legitimate
oversight that's it was of his banking
records before he was even a candidate
for office so the other thing I think I
think they're nervous about the real
investigation the real investigation is
the one that bill Barr that's like
cover-ups see they're doing the cover-up
they want to cover-up that's the drug
stage in the we talked about this last
week we never forget what bill Barr said
said there was a crisis of leadership at
the upper echelon of the FBI we know
that was the case he said spying did
occur he said third there's a basis for
my concern about the spine that took
place and then fourth he used two terms
that should frighten every one of your
viewers every single American he used
the term unauthorized surveillance and
political surveillance and Bill Barr and
John Durham and his team are committed
to finding out how this crazy thing
started and all the evidence is seeming
to point to the FBI was out to get the
president and he's going to get to the
but that's the investigation that counts
and that's the one that I think scares
all these people and that's why they're
I love this obstruction in plain sight
this is like a new lingo obstruction in
plain sight she repeated that several
times the last couple days okay speaking
of your pal Adam Schiff he was he was
wrestling with the impeachment question
today let's watch I do think that that
has to be weighed though against the the
other concern which is what does an
acquittal say
because then you have a adjudication
that this conduct is not an impeachable
offense and that is the dilemma that we
are stuck between both are equally
unpalatable think about this they're not
going to try to impeach a piece no way
they're not it because if we did Senate
might not could be in other words again
no collusion no obstruction yes so that
the Senate would come to the same
conclusion as as Muller and Barr yeah
let's be honest they're already doing
impeachment they just they just won't
formally call it that they won't take
the vote and save a character that's
there they're they're basically doing it
and the thing that I come back to is the
guy who's been on the Oversight
Committee for a long time this is not
legitimate when we were in control and
it was President Obama we did legitimate
oversight we actually looked into when
the IRS targeted people for their
political beliefs we looked into the
scandal that was fast and furious where
there was gun running and an agent a
border agent lost his life because of
that we looked into the fact that when
the tragedy in Benghazi happened and
they tried to say oh it was the catalyst
for that was some crazy video we looked
into that and of course we are currently
looking into and most importantly bill
bars looking into how the FBI can use
one party's opposition research document
as the basis to go spy on the Trump
campaign so that's legitimate oversight
what they're doing is just an attack a
lot of this is just dangling the the
it's like red meat to you know probably
dogs that haven't been favored there's
dangling it out there they have to have
to keep it out there for their base
which is their angry there I've never
seen angrier people they say Trump is
angry Trump's actually he was in a
pretty good mood I mean you talk to him
I think he gets mad like anyone else but
the anger in the fury and the seething
rage is on the Left yeah and you know
that's funny you say that lord cuz one
thing I tell the folks back home in our
district I wish every single American
could spend some time around the
president because when you're around him
the energy the charisma the love he has
for our country for our law enforcement
for our military it comes through every
single time he's not mad but they're all
mad about you know I like the fact that
he's never satisfied like well we have
4.2 percent unemployment we want it
lower I like that you want a president
who's never satisfied even with a
phenomenal time you want
to make it more people with more
manufacturing jobs for your home state
Congressman Jordan thank you so much